Dr. Peterson.
So I want to say,
um,
uh,
what a great lecture series and uh,
this is the last this year.
So Merry Christmas to you and your family.
Thank you.
I just want to say this,
this,
don't get too enthusiastic about that.
I wrote you an essay of a
question and then I use the,
uh,
the lecture of the essay writing guide
on site two 30 to narrow it down to just
a few pages,
a few lines.
And then during this,
uh,
this particular lecture,
like the Zigzag slide
manifest again and I thought,
ah,
basically just
had all my questions answered.
So,
um,
basically I just,
I want to ask,
um,
the idea of,
uh,
your,
you've made a lecture that was
on youtube many years ago and uh,
you keep referring to
Cain and Abel and the,
uh,
the death of Abel by
Cain and the Christina.
And I think that was the,
that was the single brother,
two brothers conflicting.
Um,
but,
but here we have in the
sons of Jacob the 12,
there was one who was one who's good,
one who was enable archetype and
there were 1211 that came after him.
So that,
I don't know,
maybe there's something
about the division.
No,
that's a good observation.
I hadn't thought about that.
Yeah.
Well I mean there's a bit of variability
because Ruben and Ruben isn't quite as
bad as the rest,
but yeah,
I would say it's probably
easier for the cane side,
the multiply.
Luckily it's not as powerful
because it doesn't do anything.
Yes,
yes.
And you know,
there's young was often included
accused of Manichean these,
I'm sorry I'm not
pronouncing that properly,
but there was a,
there was a variant of Christian
dogma that held that good and evil.
We're separate metaphysical realities
and that they were battling for the,
for governance of the Cosmo,
something like that.
But they both had an independent existence
and the classical Christian idea,
which won out over that was that no,
that good was real,
but evil was the absence of good.
Now that produced all sorts of the
absence of good produces all sorts of
consequences.
And it is interesting to read young
because he does get kind of Manichaean in
his discussions.
And I think it was partly because he
was so concerned about what happened in
Nazi Germany and then with
a Cold War afterwards.
You know,
cause evil seem to be a palpable force.
But I don't think that
it's as powerful as good.
But I do think it's easier for it to
multiply because it's what's easier path.
It's easy to be resentful
and hostile and bitter and,
and do nothing that's easy.
It's horrible and it's hard on people,
but it doesn't require a tremendous
amount of faith or effort.
So maybe that is why it's multiplied
in the final story in genesis.
Yeah,
and I,
I've been reading ahead and for my own,
based on the interest of the present
presented stories and I keyed in on a few
other books,
um,
chapters in the Bible,
First Corinthians 13,
which is the love chapter.
Um,
and that cycles through the idea
of I can have all things in life,
uh,
knowledge,
power,
but it's all passing.
And uh,
the law now and forever.
Faith,
hope and love.
And then of course love triumphs overall.
Yeah.
Well the love the issue.
See I've,
I've been,
I thought a lot about the relationship
between love and truth because I've
thought and talked a lot more about truth.
And I think partly that's because love
is a word that you can hardly even say
because it's been so,
it's like it's being dragged
behind a car through mud puddles.
It's something like that.
But it's so,
sorry,
let me just finish it
liberating this idea.
But I think that the,
the,
the love idea is associated with w for me,
at least with what I discussed at the
beginning of this lecture with regards to
faith,
I think you have to make a decision
about what your attitude towards being is
going to be.
And the proper attitude in my estimation
is that you're working for its
betterment,
you know?
And so maybe,
maybe you have the same attitude towards
being as you do towards someone that
you love,
like a son or a daughter or wife,
that you want things to be better.
And then so that's your aim.
So they aim is basically the
aim is motivated by love.
You want things to be better,
because I think that's a
good definition of love.
Like if you really care for someone,
you can tell because you want
things to be better for them.
And then I think truth is nested inside
that because I think that truth is the
best servant of love.
It's something like that.
[inaudible].